After you answer a question, there's typically going to be a short
video explaining the answer before moving on to the next video or topic.
>> For example, right now I'm explaining that all
the answers to the last question were correct. Go us!
>> Woohoo
[NOISE]
Now some questions are going to have right or wrong answers. If
you don't get it right the first time, don't worry about it.
>> Just pay attention to any feedback that
you see appear on the screen and try again.
>> And some questions don't have right
or wrong answers at all. These questions
are just meant to get you thinking. Or poll the class in interesting ways.
>> And remember, you should have fun answering
these questions. After all, genetics is all about fun.